2006 Devil Wears Prada are you so
confident your abilities that when
you're cast with Meryl Streep and Anne
Hathaway does that intimidate you at all
or you just don't care no I was very
intimidated
I remember the table read was Meryl and
you know we're all just quaking it's the
table read comes after you're hired
right comes off to you hired and you do
a table read where you just read through
the script you've said in that movie you
play kind of a woman that you don't like
that you would not like to hang out with
right and you in order to prepare you
went around and you found really
horrible people to emulate right where
do you find horrible people I like to
soak up people on the street and people
like me to know what do you mean soak up
people I guess I steal from people I
meet and you steal friend like I saw a
mother speaking to her child in a
supermarket when we were shooting that
film and it's a line that gets quoted
back to me now where she yelled at her
kid in a supermarket and she kind of
went like this with a hand like she's
working a puppet and she goes yeah I'm
hearing this and I want to hear this
right I put it in the movie yeah I'm
hearing this is that the secret to being
a great actress that you must observe
what people do in the mimic it part of
me sometimes feels that I think that is
that does go into it for me that's what
helps me is to kind of feel what other
people would feel like in my skin and
that that's the trick that makes sense
and other times I think it's about the
ultimate expression of empathy you have
to be so interested in people and
empathize with them profoundly it can
you easily get rid of your right like if
I said you be a typical American right
now could you easily get rid of it it's
not that easy for me how do you do what
do you have to do you have to go into a
mindset or you do being a mimic again
you just mimic you know an accent yeah
who do you mimic who do you think of
when you if I said you right now here's
a part I was in America be an American
would you go to a North East and kind of
thing a southern thing where would you
go for you I think Brits always say it's
like a standard American accent which is
probably insulting because I think
accents are very different in America is
the standard accent a Midwestern accent
no it's like a very odd
I don't even hate renée's how do you do
if I had to play a British like your
accent is not a standard American accent
that's not all we're taught as a
standard American
I'm like a New Yorker you're in New York
I have a New York actor do you know New
York accents are really hard for Brits
whereas a southern accent is easier for
some reason the rhythms and the tambour
of it is like much easier when you would
for a movie like Devil Wears Prada but
you played a British person there so
that's that's a that's right that's easy
I said do you want me to do it American
I said I'd prefer to play her British
because I think there's a sort of
superiority that works with an arrogance
and arrogance yes and it worked
yeah an imperious quality but when you
go in to see Tom Cruise and you're
thinking about he wants you to play
America but he didn't I mean most people
I think people really like the British
accent and so I'm sort of being embraced
in that way that I have done both but
can you enjoy playing an American I do
enjoy it um if it helps me sort of go in
a different direction with a character
if it helps kind of trigger a different
sort of chameleon thing but but there's
something that is not quite as
liberating for me if you're having to do
an accent when you were shooting Sicario
I understand you got sick during the
shoot did you got what they called
Montezuma's Revenge do they stop filming
or you have to do the show must go on
actually worked for the film because I
was supposed to look sweaty and
terrified because we were seeing bodies
hanging from a bridge that they were
like let's do it that's a heavy scene
right to show you got to really look
authentic in that one you walk in and a
cartel has already just wiped out all
these people and you see and you smell
them and they're dead dudes dead
carcasses there and and you and and
you're someone who has never been
traumatized like that before
not to that extent I mean she's
tactically really highly skilled at
being an FBI agent but I think what
she's exposed to in the war on drugs
it's just a whole other does the
director say to you listen you did this
is the setup you got to be really
sickened here go that's how it works and
my whole thing you know we're really
trying to find the reality of the
situation I just think when people are
really scared and really grossed out
they submarine it like people just have
this rather shocked expression in other
words the trick is most amateurs would
be like oh you know you've got all
because you're a tough FBI woman yeah
you've got to act so she's trying to say
face throughout the whole film so it's a
subtle move on
camera I think the camera sees
everything you know I've really learnt
over the years that you don't it really
sees everything so so he's acting on the
eyes you just have to feel it just feel
it out don't here's what fascinates me
so you're a little kid growing up and
you're a stutterer and a bad one I mean
I have it bad and some teacher notices
that when you act in school plays or
whatever it is you're doing and you
become a character that you don't
stutter that much what happens when you
become a character it because people who
sing say this I started that when I sing
it disappears sort of removal of
yourself from yourself type thing and I
used to really enjoy speaking in stupid
voices and I loved accents as a kid
because it was a way for me to speak
fluently and this teacher that you just
spoke about picked up on that he said
you want to be in the class play and I
said no and he said well please you know
I think you should I think you'd be
great
he said I've heard you do your bits with
your friends and do impersonations he
said I've heard you do me I've heard you
do a bunch of people why don't you just
do it in a silly voice which is amazing
that he had that kind of insight as
someone who isn't a stutterer and most
teachers don't pay attention on that
loan no the fact that he really zeroed
in on you is really good yeah mr. McHale
now here mr. McHale mr. McHale I got to
hail him because you know what that's
pretty good most teachers ignored me no
matter what I did no one saw a thing in
me